"This is life pod eight, requesting immediate assistance.
We've touched down to close to the crash sight and radiation levels to high to disembark.
According to the manifest life pods four through seven should be equipped with radiation suits
if anyone can hear this please retrieve the suits and converge on our position for evac.
Co-ordinates are attached. This message will now repeat."
OH SH*T!
I HAVE A MISSION!!
HOLY F-
Hello everybody! My name is Markplier
And welcome back to Subnautica.
Sorry for the cold open there
but apparently
lifepod eight is in trouble.
I've never actually seen that before
I need to find
life pods five through seven?
Why would only some of the life pods have...
the necessary equipment to be able do that?!
Radiation suits?
I've no idea what that is but I- (7x)
s'pose!
What I could do is I could bring these nutrient blocks with me
and a flare.
And some TATURNINURM
I don't need this much titanium I suppose I can–
AI: *Inaudible* "A new message has arrived."
Another one?!
AI: "Playing message."
Automated distress signal from Aurora Life Pod  seven, co-ordinates are attached.
WELL THERE'S SEVEN AND THERE'S EIGHT!
OH MY GOD DON'T DIE!
I think they're gonna die...
It's night.
♪ did not knoooow it was night ♪
♪ IIIIIII ♪ have a flashlight.
Ughhh, look at the beautiful underwater sea!
-that is the nightmare of my life...
Okay so supposedly...
I hate that.
HAVE I MENTIONED THAT I HATE THAT.
So supposedly
over in...
Life pod seven
There's a radiation suit. Then I can take it to life pod 8.
But there's no way there's gonna be anyone else alive here!
They're all dead!
A million ways from Sunday!
They're all DEAD!
But what's even more interesting about that is that I'm being guided towards them.
So the developers are starting to build some of the story and answer some of the weird-ass questions as to, #1,
why.. Am I the only one here...?
*Creepy, ominous sound plays*
I hate it
I hate it.
I saw- I see you in the distance over there but I still haaaAAaate it
Need AIR!
Oh, I hate it!
I- Radiation? Aw, sh*t! Well f*ck!
I can't even get over to Life pod seven!
How am I gonna be able to help 'em?
They're gonna die in the radiation zones!
Oh, those poor sons of b*tches...
That kinda has a terrible feeling! There's nothing I could do, there's too much radiation!
But if I could - if I couldn't survive, how could they?!
Oh my God, that's a new way of even thinking about this
Like, this whole endeavor of going into the ocean, like...
Before, it was just like, "Oh God I'm alone everyone's dead I guess?"
But now, everyone else isn't dead...
They're dying.
And that's a horrible feeling.
I mean the eventual goal I imagine of this game would be to have some semblance of multiplayer to this
because otherwise, you're isolated
stay on this world is going to be extremely lonely.
Alright anyways, do I have another message waiting for me?
Do I?
No...
Just the fact that I failed
Alright, i'm gonna go start building my base because
As you guys know, I don't have the lockers so I can't put ya names on'em!
I'm a big bad doofy doo~
So in the kelp forest there are pieces of the glider
which it's not the uh..
it's not the seamoth and it's gonna be a while til I get the seamoth
because i'm not gonna cheat
that's a hundred percent correct
i'm not even gonna be..
i'm not even gonna be sad about the fact that i'm not gonna cheat
I'm just gonna not do it.
But what I need to find, is I need to find the sea-glider so I can at least..
[gasp]
That was way closer than I thought it was..
I hate being down here in the dark
IIIIIIIII hate it, OHH I hate it!
..I hate it hate it ha-
AHH! Ah f*ck-
Ehh..
EeeEEHH BE LIGHT, LET THERE BE LIGHT
Okay let there be light, goddamnit.
Fub me.
Fub me good.
Fub me good just like you should.
Okay got some air so I got..
We're getting the first little bleeding elements of daylight so what we need to do is
we need to find the sea glider
Which now I mention that-
Oh my god there's so many-
Eh..
There's so many of those guys! What is that?
Is that a creature egg? I don't need that! Ewww!
It's gross!
Eugh..
I think that's a piece.. Ah, that's a piece, but he's right by it
I'mma go for it!
IIIIIIIIII AM BRAAAAAAAVE~
Habooski!
Okay- YEAH! I GOT IT! I'M OUT OF HERE BABY
OH I'm so outta here!
Alright.
So I got the sea gliiiide
sea gliiiide sea gliiiide...
So I need battery, lubricant, copper wire, and titanium and I can do all those things
because I need... acid mushroom for the battery but I can make copper wire if I get more copper ore
So i'm gonna put.. I'm gonna put the titanium burst on hold
I'm gonna go get some more copper, battery, acid mushroom sh*t goin' on
What else do I need.. copper wire, lubricant, and I need a little bit of the uh..
I need some of the seed pods uh.. ya know what I'm talking about.
Seed pods
Eurgaderk, okay so now I need seed pods
Yeah, but I need to be stealthy about it.
WHERE THEY AT? WHERE THEY AT?
Good thing they can't hear me shouting and screaming underwater.
God, that would be my one weakness that they would definitely exploit.
Aha, seed pods, should've grabbed them on the way
Okay.. Boobedeeboopdeboop, gimme, gimme, gimme
Damnit... Full after three? Oh I need to get rid of that. Get rid of that.
NO, DON'T EAT THAT! WHAT WERE YOU THINKING, YOU FREAK!
YOU FREAK!
WHAT WERE YOU THINKING? GODDAMNIT YOU WEIRDO!
Why you gotta be like that? Eat a nutrient block damnit! *Stalker snaps jaws*
Why would you eat that?!
What is wrong with you?!
Alright, but we got what we needed- oh we forgot the copper but i'm out of space so I might as well make the luuube..
Alright, got the luuuube
Alright, lemme go get the copper
*Crash makes noise*
Oh..
EHH..! What the F*CK?
What the f*ck dude?!
Did those things blow?
Oh my god..
Oh god!
Holy sh*t, what did you do to Gary?
YEee..
What the hell happened here? Creature egg..
My god..
Oh god, it's the cave of horrors..
Oh, I hate this cave...
I hate everything about it.. not this one that i'm in right now but the one over there
I remember when I first started playing this and I saw that cave and I was equally as scared as I am right now.
..and goddamnit did I not know what i'm doing but I still seem to be floundering just as much
Nope not copper.. [screech]
Where's my copper? [screech] Where's all the copper?! [mini screech]
Copper~
Yep.
Yes, okay that'll be enough.
That will be enough, I have enough!
Okay, I have more than enough which is good because I'm planning for the future
Like I should because i'm smaht! Wicked smaht!
Make da copper wire
Make uh de battery~
Mmmmmmake the seaglide.. yes, thank you very much. I needed that. Badly.
Cause it was going slow..
Inventory full?!
Load of dicks!
Right, right, right, right
Give. Yes, seaglide will increase your exploration range.
Please pack supplies for long journeys, and always stay within five kilometers of the nearest life pod or habitat-
Don't tell me what to do! You're not my dad!
You're not my real dad!
Wha- another... really?
[playing message]
"This is Aurora Lifepod 6! We've touched down within one kilometer of the crash site but our path to the rendezvous is irradiated,
and we've only got one rad. suit.
Requesting immediate assistance. Co-ordinates attached."
Really? Where? Where?!
Where are you?!
Oh, it's this one. Hang on.
Where's lifepod six?
Dang it! Why are they always so close to their radiated area?
And what are they, dead?
...Are they dead?
They're dead aren't they..
Okay I need fiber mesh if i'm gonna be able to do that.
Where do I get fiber mesh again?
What made fiber mesh? I can make a radiation suit and I should be able to do that but I need to make
I need creep vine samples, I can do that.
I shouldn't have eaten that one of em!
But i'm commin' for ya six!
There we go, okay I got two, enough for a fiber mesh
enough to make a.. a radiation suit and enough to go get life pod six and see what the f*ck is up!
Because there is a story here and I did not expect a story to be here
maybe you guys did but I certainly did not
Yeah I can make the radiation suit because I did get lead unfor- er fortunately I did get lead.
so I should be able to put this onnnn
Habooski!
Alright, am I wearing them? Yes I am, okay.
So i'm good to go?
Im commin' for ya six!
*Inaudible* D-Don't move!
Five!
Five's comin' for 'ya baby!
They better not be dead by the time I get here
I better not have been knocked out for like,  fifteen years!
But no
if they send a message after the radiation started leaking that would've been after the explosion.
Which means that.. they might be alive?
Or at least I might have been close?
Which I don't know if that's any better.
I don't think that's better at all.
I think that's..
in fact much worse
to know that I was ALMOST there to save them.
I ALMOST had friends in this lonely adventure.
And I ALMOST did what was right.
But instead I dicked around in the wa- uh..
in in the ocean and I was scared in my own shadow.
Oh man this clo-
Oh it's right there holy sh*t!
It's sunk which is not a good sign!
Did none of their float-ables work?
Oh man that's no good..
That's not good.
Oh that's the volcano, god dammnit
Okay hello?
Oh no
T+ 4 minutes?
Oh my god...
What the hell happened?!
How did this explode outta here?!
That doesn't make any sense!
Radiation gloves are there!
Radiation helmet
all their radiation equipment is here!
So I could have come over here and gotten them!
But why did it explode?!
Seriously why is this exploding here?
Let me see if.. where's the log?
Data downloads, lifepods, here we go.
Oh man
"Ma'am I need you to stay calm. We're not in immediate danger. Where are the rescue teams?
The ship didn't make it. So where are the rescue teams?
They're dead, Ma'am" we-
Wait oh oh wait aaahh!!
I thought sh-
I thought it was night!
I was just running out of air.
Jeez!
Okay, sorry about that everybody!
"So where are the rescue teams? They're dead, Ma'am. we have the rendezvous co-ordinates but the route there
is heavily irradiated from the crash sight and we still only have one rad-suit
So what are y'gonna do? If i can take the suit perhaps i can find a lead source in the area come back and
Frabricate another one for you, then we can swim to the rendezvous.
How do i know you'll not just save yourself gimme the suit, I'll go. Do you know how to properly equip-
I said I'll go"
That doesn't sound good...
That doesn't sound good at all.
And also let me put my seaglide down here I don't know why I wasn't using it because I'm a big dum, dummy.
Alright...
Man...
Oh there's another pod in-it there's another data pad here
Data pad...
Ho-boy, T+ 27 minutes
"I should've never let her leave with that rad-suit by now she's either swum to dry land" Wooh
weewooweewoowe-
"By now she-th-she's either swum to dry land or drowned trying, meanwhile the air filters aren't keeping up
with the hull breach, radiation levels in the pod are rising, I wont last much longer with out meds this would be the time
to take the easy way out if all the options on the table weren't equally horrific. -HATCH OPENS-
Help me! What happened? I tried to make it to the rendezvous but I started feeling sick barely made it back.
This is important, did the suit breach? are you contaminated? No I don't know what's wrong.
Did you set the air levels right? Yes. Did you remember to do up the zipper?
What zipper?" heh, what zipper?
"Your radiation levels shouldn't be this high.
Ma'am you've been exposed to... Ma'am? Ma'am, wake up! If you could make it off this planet, please,
don't tell people i died because i couldn't dress myself. -Life signs flat-lined.- Your secrets safe with me
I don't expect to make it off this planet" What the hell, how long was i out for?
Why are all my messages delayed and why, why are these people dying around me?
I've got another suuit...
Can i take the power cells? Oh no...
Oh no...
'Least I know how to do up my zipper...
That's so sad...
But i think i can make it to life pod seven now
Ooh yeah stare at that and use it
good job you...
Here we goooo~
Oh we're skidaddling look at us go
♪ In the middle of the niiight~ I've been gliding through the seeea~ ♪
♪ In the middle of the niiight...♪
Please don't eat meeeee~
♪ In the middle of the night...
In my pants i will PEEee ♪ Nah that's stupid
That was dumb i'm sorry 'bout that, i'm sorry everybody
WEE~ Wah OH
There we go, alright i'm going to life pod seven but something tells me it's going to be equally as sad
Oh boy...
Oh boy, we're reaching deeper waters and it's the middle of the night and i don't like it...
What's happening? What's goin' on there?
WOAH!
What the f*ck?!
*Creature says hi*
You've got and eco-system on your back dude
WOah! Hey! What the f*ck? You're gigantic, holy sh*t
*Creature tries starting a conversation*
Eugh!  Auugh!
[mark screaming]
I don't like that, oh my god i'm gonna scan you...
Yeee! I'm gonna scan you! Yee, oh f*ck, y-you're... oh Reefback, okay!
Eeh, Eh, eeh, I don't like you, you're bigger than you used to be... And your mode-
AHh!
What the f*ck was that?! (x2)
I don'wanna know, i got it!
Hoooo, they're MUCH bigger than they used to be. That is WAAaaYy bigger
Ya-I think in this update they made absolutely EVERYTHING in this place HORRIFYING and DEADLY...
Oooh no
*Sandshark growls*
Ah! you're in a Sandshark infested area,
Well Imma go get the things in'ere then try to make it outta here quickly! Quick as i can
AH!
Quick as i can! (x2
quick as i ca- what got me? What was that? Ow f*ck!
Gimme my... God damn health kit
Good thing i got this!
So's there anything around here that i should know about?
Kay, can i- YEe! kay
Lookin' (x6)
I know, I know, I know, I know it's bad, this situation's bad but i'll come here in the
DAAAYyy!
And i'll look at the loooog later!
Aah! Hate the f*cking ocean
f*ck this ocean!
f*ck everything about it!
God i would never swim around here!
Eugh!
Even if it was by myself i wouldn't go into the god damn ocean to... try to survive
s'probably would'a happened to everyone else in the life pods like they're like,
they took one look out the window and were like: "F*CK THAT SHIT! HOLY COCK, NOOooo"
Okay, so i got the log, i didn't see anything else but then again i was in a bit of a hurry because i was about to diiiiieeeee
but now that i got the thing. Ooh what's in here?
Hello! Oh it's pretty *Crash noises*
Hooo it was a mistake! (x2)
*seemingly endless Crash noises*
Ah, i shouldn't of come here! Hoo-wah they're screaming at me!
Why are they screaming at me?!
OOoh! wow, i'm glad that went through
Okay was, that was a detour i probably shouldn't of taken there
Bad idea (x3)
Okay I'm back yaay! It's mee, it's a me Markiplier!
Back again with, uh, a data log i guess
"Damnit how are we gonna find the other-w-others with out a rendezvous signal? We have a baring of where the
other pods went down there's a compass in the locker, we have options.
Wait you just wanna swim for it? Are you serious?
Have to eventually, if there's any rescue coming it's months maybe YEARS away, we find the others
patch up Aurora's long range com's and set about building a permanent habitat.
Did you stop to pick up your tools, while you were running for your life?
No, but the fabricator's not broken, all we need are some basic materials
I'm going out there to see what i can find"...
And they didn't make it back, cuz they were in a more hostile area than i was
So that's my only theory, the only reason that i survived is because mmmy pod, Eugh, is the only one that landed
in 'The Safezone'
Every other zone was either to close to the Aurora to survive the radiation or... in the depths where they got
eaten alive instantaniously...
That's a horrifying though... My god!
But anyway! I guess we're doin' pretty good so i got the seaglide
I've got the uh, I've got the frabricator, so in the next episode immina actually get to building a base.
And building up and... trying to survive here and get the rest of the stuff, but the story is
moving forward here and i still have sea pod eight to look for because... Immina keep sea pod seven and eight here
cuz i needed to double check sea pod seven but life pod eight is still a mystery but
chances are they're still dead right?!
Okay that's gonna be fun.
*outtro music fades in*
So, THANK YOU everybody so much for watching, And as always I will see YOU... In the next video! Buh-Byyyye~!
Thanks for the sh*t
*outtro music*